الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير توتن اواخر عامي
موتشنا لكاسحه الجليد النوويه ياكوتيا
ولكن اللقطه الاهم هي اعلانه عن البدء في
بناء كاسحه اكبر واحدث سيفوق طولها
المئتين متر وبقدره ازاحه تفوق 70000 طن
ولكن اقوى مافيها هو رمزيه اسمها فقد
سماها بوتين روسيا
اعاده عن امتلاكهم لقواعد عسكريه في القطب
الشمالي ذهب الرسول سنوات على تنظيم
مناورات في القطب لاعداد قوات قوامها
الالاف على اساليب الحرب في المناطق
المتجمده من جانبه حلف شمال الاطلسي ينظم
برامج تدريب لقوات الدول الاعضاء حتى تكون
قادره على مجابهه التفوق الروسي
البيت الابيض كان قد نشر وثيقه عنوانها
استراتيجيه القطب الشمالي التي تمتد لعشر
سنوات مقبله وترتكز على اربع اسوس زياده
الوجود العسكري تطوير الدفاعات الجويه
زياده عدد كاسات الجليد وتطوير قدرات
الرصد الجوي والخرائط
الصراع في القطب لا يدور حول السيطره على
مساحه ضخمه من الجليد بل يتمحور حول ما
يوجد تحتها من ثروات معدنيه
السويد مثلا بدات بالاستثمار في مناجم
المعادن النادره المستخدمه في صناعه
الرقائق الالكترونيه
وبطاريات السيارات الكهربائيه كما ان
الدراسات اظهرت امكانيه وجود كميات مهمه
من الطاقه
المواجهه بين روسيا والغرب في القطب
الشمالي حاليا ما تزال في مراحلها الاولى
نظرا لانشغال الجميع بالحرب في اوكرانيا
حسب مراقبين ولكنها مرشحه للتصعيد في اي
وقت لانه روسيا تعتبر الخطبه مفتاحا
لامنها القومي وتنميتها الاقتصاديه
انس نماسي العربيه